legend tells of a legendary warrior
narration also whose kung fu skills were
the stuff of legend
legend legend legendary legend legend
pure awesomeness sin will be
representative of all the films
instances of overly enthusiastic slang
in lieu of jokes
it's the DreamWorks way how to poke it
down from that high up so quickly
he's either master teleportation in his
fantasy or this is later all his former
foes are gone it's just raining cats and
dogs have been so feared and so loved
pandas of the past have set a pretty low
bar for both of those pandas mostly just
lay around eat bamboo and don't have sex
the Furious Five seem rather nonchalant
about being on fire the Furious Five I
wonder how much DreamWorks had to pay
Neal Moritz to call him that we should
hang out
why is monkey the only one who wants to
hang out with it even his own fantasy
also this is one of the seven brief
times Jackie Chan has monkey gets to
speak yr pose dream slash fantasies
two-dimensional is that small cup his
bed lurked Pan dicing po was able to
fall down the stairs without cutting it
out of his hand with the ninja star he's
older how is Bo's father a duck I mean
I'm all for adoption or animal based
movies but in early China a duck
adopting a panda I just don't see it po
falls down the stairs gets up and picks
up the radishes with both hands yet a
ninja star ends up in these noodles it's
possible that ping News's ninja stars as
a garnish but that doesn't explain the
we're about so the one po was previously
holding I don't know a lot about cooking
noodles or owning a noodle restaurant is
the only qualification having a dream
about noodles specifically the noodle
dream I didn't have a dream about making
fun of movies for a living oh wait yeah
I did
how are those rabbits not super pissed
that PO and his dad are just
chit-chatting and not serving them soup
I hope that was a challenging special
order for that pig if not I don't
understand how this is the most popular
noodle shop in the Valley of Peace took
that pig forever to get his noodles this
will all be different if they had yep
didn't you ever know want to do
something else something besides noodles
it's the hero has dreamed beyond what
his family wants cliche even though
being a fourth generation restaurateur
sounds like a pretty nice gig I thought
about running away and learning how to
make tofu so why didn't you oh because
it was a stupid dream po is not telling
his father that this is not only
something he could still accomplish but
also a smart business decision to expand
his menu Nick
tofu will be thoroughly eviscerates tofu
also why do some of the noodle soup
patrons get table service while the
others pick up at the counter and does
he really need to know the tables I feel
like he could just pass out noodles to
whoever doesn't have noodles -
numerosity monkey greater speed crane hi
out of all curt one-word feedback
sessions the most shameful is crane
needing more height he's actually a
flying bird who doesn't need kung fu to
do what birds naturally do hilarity
aside shouldn't Master Oogway possess
some kind of wind altering power that
would allow him to blow out all the
candles with a simple tool to the staff
or does he need to attend the Lord
Blackwood School of extinguishment also
holy Jesus it must have taken him
forever to light those candles
I bet DreamWorks is working on a prequel
we're way is lighting candles and Poe is
trying to stick ninja stars in his
bedroom wall for an hour and a half
Master Shifu attended the Lord Blackwood
School of extinguishment and didn't
invite anyone else so do all the
creatures of this universe have low
resolution memories or is it just Shifu
and Po Tai Lung will return that is
impossible is in prison well it would be
impossible if he was dead this movie
teaching children the lesson that it's
better to execute your enemies instead
instead of magic staff does this turtle
use magic why not use magic instead of
kung fu
doodles all of them selling noodles po
does not know the difference between
wanting a different job and actively
trying to put his family out of business
where does he think the money for his
ninja stars comes from the valley of
peace exclusively consists of pigs geese
and rabbits this is just another prime
example of Hollywood Pig geese rabbit
washing so did the Furious Five get
dropped out of a helicopter or do they
all have the ability to jump 400 feet
into the air why the hell is there a
lone small hole awkwardly placed in the
top right corner of this wall maybe they
were training one day and someone said
man it's hot could someone open a small
hole in the wall and someone else
responded there isn't one we should have
one install a thousand tons of fire
I was disappointed to find out there is
not an adult movie called this also
there are very clearly 43 missiles in
that thing but I guess 43 tongues of
fire didn't have as good a ring to it
every time I see them all together I
think to myself there are four of them
why are they called the Furious Five oh
wait I didn't see the Mantis that's
racist
surviving the 400 foot fall should be
further evidence to Shifu and the five
that he is in fact the Dragon Warrior
the universe has taught us that Dragon
Warrior
choosing the Dragon Warrior is an
incredibly vague process the oldest dude
just points randomly and whatever is in
front of his finger is the winner there
are no accidents not believing in
accidents escape from prison
dialogue that would not need to be
spoken if it were ultimately true 1000
guards and one prisoner all subsidized
by Valley of Peace tax dollars
ridiculous what must the taxes be like
for these citizens behold Thai zone
between letting a random messenger in to
see the world's most guarded prisoner
and the haphazard way they chose Dragon
Warrior I'm concerned about this ancient
Chinese animal society's looseness with
safety and protocol they made me Google
does China have rhinos I'm not watching
Kung Fu Panda to learn people flying the
sword of Heroes the invisible dragon
just me it's almost like pose a weird
this is a movie and he needs to explain
everything he is seeing so we can know
why he's freaking out otherwise he's
just talking to himself you will never
be the Dragon Warrior until you have
learned the secret of the dragon scroll
so um how does this work do you have a
ladder trampoline or perhaps a chair and
some fireworks or maybe one of the
Furious Five could just jump up there
and get it pose panda tooth looks
suspiciously like a human tooth Poe
didn't die after falling into the kung
fu training area slash deathtrap
granted that would make for a pretty
short and dark kids cartoon so is this
duck there slave just ask him oh you
even see his toes this is two of the
seven times Jackie Chan gets to speak do
P protagonists here's the cool kids
talking bad about him behind his back
cliche also why is PO hiding out behind
rocks along an obscure walkway in the
middle of the night so it is trying to
use these kind of paper screens the same
way Japan does Kung Fu Panda stop trying
to make me learn who may not have any
kung-fu skills at this point but his
talking with a mouthful of peaches
skills are on point quit don't quit no
told don't noodles don't noodles what
everyone maybe interpreting a suit
weighs wisdom is really just ways
Alzheimer's I can only assume that Tai
lungs back muscles are filled with
compressed air because if not there's no
way to explain these rods flying out of
back with this high velocity for such a
high quality prison run by rhinos they
really didn't think through the
restraining process even though this
prison is completely dedicated to Tai
Lung it's clear that he can escape if he
just has any piece of anything I guess I
can excuse the tiger with super strength
that can lift two-ton boulders on either
side of him without having his arms
ripped off but what I still can't excuse
is this prison feeling that this was a
better solution than just bolting the
chains down to the pillar he was
standing on this takes the henchmen are
terrible shots cliche to a whole new
level they have giant crossbow Zhan
mounts and he is still relatively
restrained so this was pure luck for Tai
Lung which brings up the question what
was his plan if this didn't happen was
he just gonna pull those giant heavy
rocks up and hope for the best
Rhino Clarke Duncan also Rhino nipple
this escape is brought to you by cartoon
physics allowing Bugs Bunny to thwart
otherwise khals since 1938 this guard
isn't acknowledging that he has already
gotten pretty far even dealing with this
very implausible escape how exactly did
Tai Lung make it out of that fall I
guess the animators got too lazy to
animate him out of that last predicament
so they just ignored it all together
rhino helm screen didn't place any of
those 1000 guards around the perimeter
huh and the dynamite would have gone off
by now
did Thailand disintegrate him why are we
just seeing this copper horn shield that
has no obvious purpose drop to the
ground fly back there and tell them the
real Dragon Warrior is coming home this
makes for a cool movie moment of
evilness I guess but in no way does this
make any military sense for the villain
to do this this is a thousand times
worse than monologuing
sending advanced word to the enemy slash
good guys that you're coming cocky is
one thing stupid is another is the
animal that comes out of the room first
get some sort of prize this extreme
urgency would otherwise be pointless
so I guess sheep who's planning is have
the Furious Five beat the shit out of
him until he decides to go home I
thought this with a family movie cartoon
or not Poe is dead but he will another
reminder that Jackie Chan got paid
handsomely to save five sentence
fragments and two complete sentences
that will come later but if I didn't
know any better I'd say he was trying to
get rid of me what gave it away
was at the moment where he literally
kicked you out of the Jade Palace Shifu
found him
well not so much found as was given
anonymously this is ancient Chinese
society that is
of animals and that also has magic have
stigma against unwed mothers too and he
raised him as his son father-son dynamic
and wholly unoriginal dynamic - the hero
/ villain dynamic in this movie dynamic
but Oogway saw darkness in his heart and
refused more Yoda Anakin ripoff this is
what I'm talking about with the magic
why does make the proto J's go through
literal kungfu gauntlets when there is
obviously magic that can be taught are
we sure this turtle is on the up-and-up
and he's stuck with you a big fat Panda
everyone keeps picking on PO for being
fat but pandas are fat there's nothing
to be done about it
no one gives the snake and he for not
having arms there are no accidents
not believing in accidents someone needs
to tell Shifu that not every moment
requires kung foo my time has come you
must continue your journey without me
Liu Bei heard that Tai Lung was coming
and he accidentally picked a fat Panda
to beat the Dragon Warrior so he is
getting the fuck out of Dodge this is
the most useless magic turtle I've ever
seen
what is his MO did he drop off evil Tai
Lung at the martial arts center to prove
a point about fate or something tigress
you've got to try these
three cheers for Jackie Chan's fourth
line you awesome movie you can totally
see that what need to ask what before
slurping movie rips off the doing and
impression of the cranky person when the
cranky person walks in on you thing from
all the movies let us stop Tai Lung this
is what you've trained us for naught
he'd train them to defeat he who has
already been defeated and subsequently
imprisoned it's convenient that he broke
out or all of their training would have
been a waste of time
Shifu apparently doesn't notice the 5
are missing for a long time while he
trains Po the pool of sacred tears
funny enough the pool of sacred tears
was the name of my band in eighth grade
when you had been trained you may eat so
basically she flew his training PO the
same way I trained my dog to sit stay
and roll over the inevitable training
montage we all knew was coming
imagine Jack Black in a booth recording
come few sounds for the scene I highly
doubt that PO would be motivated by a
bowl of steamed carrots and lettuce how
did they get that soup up there and how
is that not burned the crowd of his
hands and head and you have been trained
you are free to eat Wow years of Kung Fu
training mastered in a business week he
must really be the Dragon Warrior kung
fu dumpling hockey Wow the kung fu
version of the shell game is being
unfair as hell I'm not hungry
Shifu shouldn't be hungry either he ate
all the dumplings which raises the
question why is she foo viewing this as
PO being successful he only got one of
the eleven dumplings this is a kung fu
where he can quantifiably see who the
winner is man prison is really far away
dude home so that is his name PO monkey
pulls the airport police chief dick move
of naming the warrior to the villain
from die hard to I don't see why it's
such a big deal that tigress falls she
can just do a flip right before she to
the ground and she'll be fine I know we
have taken some pretty serious liberties
with physics in the movie but mantas
holding the rope bridge with all his
friends on it seems far-fetched even for
the universe filled with kung fu
fighting animals I love how the five are
renowned for their greatness but due to
the movies overhyping of the Dragon
Warrior four of the five can't take out
a bad guy together which is some both
Bruce Lee was a badass but against four
other badasses he'd have lost dog that
should have killed him right is he dead
I'm willing to suspend disbelief for
animal kung fu scenes that involve a
mantis holding up a giant rope bridge
filled with tigers and leopards but
smacking into the rocks like that it's
gotta bust up a skull never mind why is
the nerve attack accompanied with a Pink
Floyd laser show on the recipients body
also even though it is a very quick and
powerful way to stop your opponent this
is the first time we've seen Tai Lung
use it even after fighting the Furious
Five just now on all the guards and the
true oricon prison also why not just
kill them you have done well panda so
well in fact that I have not only not
worried about the missing five warriors
but I haven't even noticed they are gone
the mark of a true hero is humility yeah
tell that to Cam Newton yep he paralyzed
four of the five and left the flying
woman to return them home but somehow
also allowed all that to happen before
his own arrival paralyzed these four and
then what wait in the bushes for a while
watch Netflix the fuck did this guy wait
around so long for and if you tell me
it's so the five would all make it home
in time to make the Battle of challenge
I'll tell you he's the worst bad guy
ever he doesn't want to win he wants to
lose but only when facing everyone fast
sorry Pope for those of you keeping
score at home that's five lines for mr.
Chan white is undoing the nerve attack
look like Shifu was a chiropractor for
viper and tigress
but for mantis and monkey it looks like
he's unlocking an iPhone so kung fu is
flower petal magic invented by a turtle
got it no one seems the slightest bit
concern that cranes neck is visibly
broken Cogley to one that's funny mama
maybe they realized they didn't give
Jackie Chan enough to say is this movie
went on so they wrote in some complete
sentences form even though what he said
still contributes nothing to the storm
how the actual did he manage to do this
we will continue to ignore the no thumbs
rule that has been violated numerous
times in this movie
but I can't ignore that as arm slash
wings don't even reach to pose sides
maybe paying is also a kung-fu master
who was able to manipulate objects with
his mind to make something special you
just have to believe it's special ah the
old there's actually nothing special
about blank you just have to believe in
yourself cliche what when Google said
otherwise what did you do this flashback
a Bouygues saying no it's different from
the other flashback a Moog way saying no
the new way tell Shifu and Tai Lung that
he couldn't have the Dragon scroll two
separate times or was tigress just
completely making up that previous
flashback in her own mind there's a
terrible draft at the Hall of warriors
someone should show the window so those
peak tree petals stop coming in
no one from Shifu to PO bothers to tell
this dude the pink scroll is blank I
mean what happens if PO stops the fight
right here just gives the scroll to tile
up he reads it finds it blank and then
what he's still gonna kill everyone Amy
even has an existential crisis and goes
into a trance
my point is fighting the stood over a
worthless scroll is pointless I think PO
is the Dragon Warrior because he's a
boneless gelatinous blob that cannot
feel pain maybe the reason Shifu came so
close to being defeated just now is he
didn't fight silly enough holy that
building was brittle the goose pig a
rabbit that conducted the building
inspection clearly didn't check the
load-bearing studs matrix panned
illusions PO basically jar jar's himself
through this entire movie so the Panda
makes a crater but Tai Lung makes a wily
coyote hole when he hits the ground this
will be switches between real physics
and cartoon physics so many times it's
dizzying pickle a yo
music playing right now sounds like look
away look away look away Dixieland and
now you will hear that forever you're
welcome go get something to eat so now
the PO is officially the Dragon Warrior
he and Shifu have the same relationship
as college roommates
what you want me to teach you something
you wouldn't learn something all right
here's a useful lesson for you give up
just quit
do I'll do not there is no try
carnage nothing you were not meant to be
the Dragon Warrior the chosen one